if the weather man is to be believed we
got a big ice and snow event coming so
we got a lot to do today to get ready
for it so let's get to
work got to do a little work on my uh
gate up here at the entrance to our
place cows have rubbed the toost
loosened it up got to drive it in a
little farther uh then I need to grease
the gate this gate the hinges need to be
greased every few months doesn't take
much this TST that the gate comes up
against during the night time when the
gaug is closed the cow's rub on it you
can see it's all loose needs to be
driven in a little
farther got this automatic gate opener
it's really handy but it's gotten a
little bit out of adjustment doesn't
quite close liks about 3 or 4 in so so
I'm going to make a couple of rounds
adjustment there and hopefully that'll
do
[Music]
it this Gate's been really handy because
the Cales don't respect the cattle guard
so I have to close this at night
time still needs a little bit more
adjustment
got to give it a couple more turns
didn't quite get it enough
there that's no better I guess we're
just going to have to leave it that way
or till I read the owner's manual and
figure out another way to do it we also
got the gate down here at the Creek
Place it needs to be greased as well a
little cold today so that grease is a
tad stiff
watch out pigs watch
out it's only the second day of
captivity and Roger has already learned
to eat and getting right in there with
the big
boys good back girls
lots of things to do today before the
expected winter storm arrives but extra
feeding is the order of the day at every
place I have several cows that are
really fat but this one right in front
of us right now
578 one of the reasons she's so fat is
ever since I've had she has sucked other
cows after they've had a calf and most
people would get rid of her but she
doesn't seem to get enough to hurt the
Cales so I just keep her but that's why
she's so fat I'm feeding these cows hay
every other day till the weather gets
bad it's supposed to get bad this
weekend and stay bad for a week so it's
pretty soon I'll have to start feeding
them hay every day but I'm trying to
stretch that out as long as I can and as
you can see the cows are in really good
shape so they don't need a lot of extra
feed right now but probably as the
weather gets bad next week they'll start
getting hay every day just to give them
enough
[Music]
energy counted these cows and I'm
missing one so we got to go find
one and as I suspected it's The
Loner one with a dot in her face off
barell before I start feeding hay every
day I usually try to spread out cubes
right beside the hay that I fed
yesterday so that when they finish the
cubes hopefully they'll go clean up that
hay that they haven't quite cleaned
up got to wrap up this water Outlet out
here in the yard before the singled
digit temperatures occur these old
insulated coveralls were worned by both
of my sons when they were back on the
Farm but that's been 25 years ago I'm
pretty sure they won't fit either one of
them now so we'll just use them for
insulation now that really cold
weather's here I have to plug this
little feeding tractor in every morning
for an hour or two before it starts it
doesn't have glow plugs like my big
tractor so this helps it start a lot
easier on these cold
mornings winter used to be my favorite
season of the year on the farm I enjoy
feeding the cattle hay and watching the
the new baby be born I still like it but
the older I get the better I seem to
like spring and fall we're expecting a
big ice storm starting uh this afternoon
or tonight so the wind is out of the
East I'm going to spread this bail out
on the west side of this Timber so it's
a little bit warmer for them and then I
got to go up to the pond and check out
where I'm going to have to chop ice I
don't know since we've cleaned the pond
out so I got to take a look at it and
see what where I'm going to chop ice cuz
we're going to need to chop ice either
tomorrow morning or the morning after
Winter's
here you can tell a lot about what kind
of weather is in store by observing
livestock and as hungry as these cattle
seem today I believe that we're in for
falling weather and I'm not looking
forward to
it but if the cattle and the weather
forecasters are right at least it does
give me a chance today to get some of
the things set up for the Colder Weather
with the bail rings and Waters and
things like
that with this freezing rain and snow
coming I wanted to get the bail rings
out and get them set up because probably
if it gets really bad we'll have to put
some hay in the bail Rings instead of
unrolling it
got to find a place where it's going to
be deep enough to chop ice and the cows
look like they're used to coming here
but that doesn't
look very deep
there I think that'll work right here
though
maybe today before the storm arrives I'm
trying to unroll hay in places that'll
maybe be sheltered from the winter
weather a little bit the blowing uh wind
and snow and ice that we're expected to
get try to put the hay along these tree
lines and maybe protect it from the
weather a little bit more well Lou and I
both agree it's time to call it a day
[Music]